we think now that we must apply downward  pressure further downward pressure on  that upward curve by closing the school  so I can announce today and Gavin  Williamson is making a statement now in  that in the House of Commons that after  schools shut their gates from Friday  afternoon they will remain closed for  most pupils for the vast majority of  pupils until further notice we're making  provisions to supply meals and vouchers  for children eligible for free school  meals and where some schools are already  doing this I wanna make it clear that we  will reimburse the cost and of course  this does mean that exams will not take  place as planned in May and June though  we will make sure that pupils get the  qualifications they need and deserve for  their academic career